complex relationships and communication
are at the heart of movies by the
oscar-winning producer Brian Grazer took
me a long time to understand that if you
want to do this job well you have to
stay detached the truth is that I I
don't like people much our case is
simply this oh now you can't speak
English say again please houston we have
a problem now grazer has put what he's
learned over the years into a new book
it's called face to face the art of
human connection the book was published
by Simon & Schuster that is a division
of CBS and Brian joins us right now at
the table Brian how are you great thanks
yeah you say in the book that eye
contact is your kind of secret weapon
when you're feeling uneasy now that's
interesting because most people hear the
opposite you're supposed to picture
people in their underwear anywhere but
into their eyes because that's gonna
make you scared so why does it work for
you what has a good eye I think because
I'm in the feelings business and
everything is about feelings so when I
connect to somebody and I sort of say
using your eye contact is the human
Wi-Fi when I look at somebody it
actually calms me
well it humanizes them and and and I'm
sure I'm humanized to them as well if
you were a shy kid so how did you I was
dyslexic kid so I was kind of I couldn't
read it all and so the very first part
of my life I didn't actually look at
people at all because I was afraid I'd
be called in class like come up and
what's the answer yeah and so then there
was a point where I realized by looking
at somebody I could learn much more and
I could make it an interactive
experience and then exercise this muscle
of curiosity yeah
Ron Howard pointed out to you that you
don't look people in the eye somebody
told me once if you don't want to look
people in the eye Brian look at their
nose because it looks like you're
looking at but Ron Howard waited out to
you
I know but Ron Howard said you don't
look people at the eye and what what did
you get from that conversation well it
was unusual because it was on our second
movie splash you guys are partners yes
we're partners and we're working with
the writers and I was able to like
understand everything they were saying
and I
like every bit of the mechanics of what
was going on and he said Brian I are you
really paying attention to Lola Bible
who I said I am and I said I'll repeat
everything that had just happened and of
course I was you know very operable you
know I could do it but then he said but
when you don't look at them it makes
them feel bad it hurts their feelings
and he just said it with the simplicity
of that and it really penetrated me you
said true love starts with the eyes it
definitely started a great story of that
when you met your wife how she came into
a restaurant and that you your eyes
connected across a room do you really
think that true love and you have to
have a spirit to spirit connection by
looking in somebody's eyes I really do
but work because your wife is your wife
and what is it about the eyes you said
you can't really you can't have a
one-sided connection yeah well what is
good with the eyes it's not it's not
that cliche of like I see into your soul
but it's a bridge into the person and
because I'm in the business of reaching
people emotionally and a camera is a
magnifier when I look into someone's
eyes and they into mine and I'm calm and
they're calm and you're present you have
a chance to reach each other's heart
yeah yeah you said deals are made
connection right and that's there's no
making a connection and you really
you're not getting a promotion without a
connection you're not getting and making
a deal you're not doing your be round
none of those things are happening
without a connection how do we overcome
the iPhones
well iPhones are really they're smart
devices they're very valuable but I
think there should be used independently
they are compatible to one another but
you can't really pay attention to
somebody and be present if you're
looking at your iPhone look at your
iPhone before yeah the authentic
connection guys he says take 7 to 10
seconds alone yes in a group it's 3 to 5
seconds yes to make eye contact exactly
like that without people thinking you're
weird so get off your phones unless of
course you're reading face-to-face by
Brian Grazer yes so face to face the
heart the art of human connection goes
on sale tomorrow